Brian Austin Green sharing several rare  photos of his three sons with wife Megan  Fox people love it  he first posted this pic of two-year-old  Bodhi rocking a red wig then we got this  shot Bodhi with his four-year-old  brother Noah Brian wrote quote I miss  being young the nine are two and Oh LM  also gushed over how handsome Noah is on  this solo snap quote crazy how  good-looking he is and Brian also  praised his wife's genetics sharing this  pic of their newest son journey River  quote my wife makes beautiful babies  Megan and Brian welcomed journey  earlier this year Megan told ET just how  Noah and Bodhi were preparing for a baby  brother Bodhi is too young like he gets  it but he's he's still like in that sort  of oblivious phase but no was really  excited he's actually really maternal he  can't wait to feed and hold and pet the  baby and he is he's really he's  practicing a lot with baby dolls and  he's doing a good job  you